ROUND IT OUT DEFENSIVELY.
OR LIN.
FINDS THE STICK OF ROBERTSON, IN
BORGEN IS THE BUFRING WHY THERE
WASN'T SOMETHING CALLED AS HE
ENDED UPIR COACH'S CHALLENGE
TO SEE IF THERE WAS GOAL TENDER
INTERFERENCE PRIOR TO THE  ARE .
WE TALKED ABOUT THE ENERGY
LEVEL, THE C SHOT.
RASK TO TOE
DIDN'T TAKE THAT.
LOOKED LIKE HE HAD A FREE LINE.
>> Josh: GOURDE.
CARRIES IT BACK ININ8:30 ON BAL
SOUTHWEST.
A HEART BREAKER FOR DALLAS JUST
BEFORE WE WENT ON THE
>> Daryl: FACE-OFF WINS, MAN, IN
THIS LEAGUE RIGHT NOW,FACE-OFF.
HERE'S McCANN.
THE
MISFIRED.
>> Daryl: CAUGHT THE STARS ON A
PRESSURED BY SEGUIN.
ALMOST STRIPPED IT AWAY FROM THE
NET MINDER. HILLARY CLINTON
STICK.
GAVE INTO BY RAFFL.
RASK CHANCES. STEALS IT.
HE WILL FEED TO OLEKSIAK.
OLEKSIAK, THE RIGHT SIDE,
POFIRST.
BACK DOOR PASS
GOTTEN IT TO GO.
>> Josh: THEY ARE OUT THERE,
RIGHT NOW, FLANKING TO
IT.
N SPINS AWAY.
KLINGBERG HAS TIME AND SPACE.
THE KRAKEN HAVEE BACKHAND AWAY.
STAR FIRST FORAY TO THE NET HE
DRIVES INTO
NAMESTNIKOV.
BANK PASS.'S A BAD TURNOVER BY
HAD.
>> Daryl: GORGEOUS.
>> Josh:
BOUNCES.
STARS FOR SEATTLE.
DUNN, SOUCY, HE WILL BANK IT
TR